курс угорець служив у бундесвері акули
пішов за вислугу уроки у проїхав до
одеси і заснула тут ці компанію за цим
рокки у проживання бізнесмена в Україні
змінилося від риб резиденти алісу слова
миша винга розумом і для бізнесу завищувала
собі змін виняток пориві річки та
бюрократичні океани на profit нового
губернатора Михайла Саакашвілі в сили в
надій у нас міни на початку спірит ноша
не skype такими у сильній і всякий
ашвіллі було п'ятдесят на п'ятдесят
алла через три місяці його працює при
сильної квт corby частина три місяці тому
рішення президента України означає і
Саакашвілі губернатором одягу став він
переляку вам і поспішає не в його роботи
стало відразу милість околиш не президент
грузії з'ївши за вій у змії вилися
ходити став екрану у tatra nuits розум
знов та поліція що відкриваючи для udacity
пляжі самовільно zoho плані олігархами
коли голи він шукає рубля для себе
закон ньому написано
як телику для народу покарають ми
сходні з вами Михайлом Миколайовичем або
зрозуміло закону німа ви зловите
закону немає белль 6 одеситів подібне
c1000 губернатор регулярно виходять на
вулиці і вид вертута я мутін встиг кується
з людьми тпр он і надають саакашвілі
великий кредит a very хочеться сказати
ще ми навіть заради що гвинт у нас прийшов
було якось сподіваюся я була тих людей на
зраді на краще, проте ламання park new
під прицілом відеокамер we для колод ж
холонуть з ideo
з теж погано ставлю сюди піару
я вболівала за над
я ваша реклама ти parkan ii c загориться
критикував саакашвілі та затягни вину за
свої команди марія гайдар
опозиційного політика за русі і не
знаю йому з українським реалі а ми он вона
стрибала та кімчі нам отримала по саду і
не пропустіть ігрових Михайло Саакашвілі
та кулачів ніж моя біографія одна з
колядою прогулювала моно йому хай так
конкурс і пройшла у перчі 2 ти ж
не свій роботи саакашвілі скоро ти
апарат облдержадміністрації на 300 у сіп
по team win a su б 100 провис
з Києва наказ правильно не начальника
Іллічівського порту d процвітала
контрабанда а дня ми саакашвілі праворуч
qual великий скандал ж у ківі віндою ви
усі люди ув'язнення президент аптекарку
yanukovych і не витрачав і слова за його
на владу саакашвілі примус винного
прикладу яценюка в імітації реформ запасі
за втомися ерік ідеальності тягу ряду і
прем'єр-міністра за б так заданий дар
шпик прийому сам україни обчислиться і
ближній
100 мільярдам гри в тибет спадкоємство
приносять дахід аль і приносить його
олігархам але вони прекрасні та під
олігархів буркнув ідеальний саакашвілі
за б заспівати що йому популярні серед
населення на офіційному сайті
президента України паршивого разів не
активісти розмістив і петицію з ви
мовою визнали і главу одещини
прем'єр-міністром України за ти ж день
плями та підписалося опа на 21000 вусик на
думка німецького бізнесмена schwing гора
як що саакашвілі в досьє на вагу тіла в
одесі той день ще на свічка теми про ти
такого перетину